كشفنا ابو رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني
مالك عكر ان هيئه الايجاد اقترحت لقاءا
بين رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان وقائد قوات الدعم السريع
محمد حمدان حميدتي ويجري الترتيب لعقده
بعد اسبوعين في احدى دول الايجاد وشدد
عقار في تصريح للجزيره على ان الخلافات لا
تنتهي الا من خلال التفاوض
في يعني لقاء بين بين الطرفين واللي هو
اللي غابه
رئيس مجلس السياده الفريق
وبين قائد قوات الدعم السريه لاتفاق على
وقفه الادعيات والقضايا الانسانيه وقضايا
والقضايا التي ادت الى الحرب
وقال ملك عقار للجزيره ان العمل جارا
لايقاف الحرب والعوده الى طاوله المفاوضات
واكد عقار ان الاولويه الان تتمثل في
ضروره وجود جيش واحد تحت قياده واحده حسب
قوله
نحن يعني بنعمل بانه هذا الحرب يقيف
والناس يرجعوا الى طاوله
التفاوض لمعالجه القضايا الملحه التي ادت
الى الى هذا الحرب ولمعالجه القضيه
السوداء السودانيه فيما بعد ذلك لكن نحن
دايرين نوقف الحرب ونعالج القضيه الانيه
التي ادت الى الحرب بحيث انه القضيه التي
عدت الى حرب تكون هنالك في السودان جيش
واحد موحد تحت قياده واحده